a master of Japanese animation has come
out of retirement so let's light a fire
and take to the skies as the boy and the
Heron makes its way to American theaters
when production for the boy and the
Heron began in 2016 it was a slow
process with director hayom aaki
reportedly directing a minute of
Animation every month the release date
was at one point supposed to coincide
with the 2020 Summer Olympics in Tokyo
the games ended up being delayed to 2021
because of the covid-19 pandemic but the
boy and the Heron still wasn't ready in
time in December 2022 Studio jibli
confirmed that the movie would arrive in
Japanese Cinemas the following summer
and indeed the boy and the Heron opened
on July 14th 2023 G kids has acquired
the rights to release the film in North
America and it will hit Cinemas
Nationwide on December 8th 2023 it had
its North American Premiere at the
Toronto International Film Festival on
September 7th and then its us Premiere
happened at the New York Film Festival
the boy and the Heron features several
well-known Japanese voice actors though
the main character is played by a
relative newcomer s santoki who only
started acting in 2019 and has less than
half a dozen credits to his name kosi
basaki and masaki suda also star and
there's a special appearance from takuya
Kimura the cast for the English dubbed
version is also quite the star studded
Affair Christian Bale is voicing shoichi
the father of the main character his son
is being played by Luca padavan who's
probably best known for the Thriller
series youu the mystical Heron of the
title is being voiced by none other than
Robert pson the rest of the English cast
consists of jeach Chan Willam defo
Florence Pew Karen fukuhara Dave Batista
and Mark Hamill the man in the
director's chair for the boy and the
Heron is hay Miyazaki who is perhaps the
biggest name in the history of Japanese
animation this is the first movie he's
directed since 2013's The Wind Rises it
will be his 12th feature film and
supposedly his last however it should be
noted that this isn't the first time
that Miyazaki has teased the end of his
career he first announced his retirement
in the late '90s before returning to
direct Spirited Away in 2001 he retired
again in 2013 and then once more in 2018
producer toshio Suzuki is skeptical this
time as well as he put it in a recent
interview I don't believe it as long as
he lives Miyazaki will probably continue
to make films whether the boy and the
Heron ends up being miyazaki's swans
song or not the buzz is making it clear
that it is not to be missed the boy and
the Heron is partly inspired by the 1937
Japanese novel how do you live which is
about a 15-year-old boy in Tokyo whose
father has died and who is close with
his uncle hay Miyazaki has called it his
favorite childhood book though the film
isn't a straight adaptation of the story
instead it's about someone who loves the
book this isn't the first time that
Miyazaki has been inspired by literature
while taking his movie story in a unique
Direction 2004's how's Moving Castle was
Loosely based on a novel of the same
name though it differed from The Source
material in numerous ways for one thing
there's no war in the book military
conflict is also a backdrop for the boy
and the Heron it set during World War II
to and follows a boy named mahito whose
mother died when Tokyo was bombed mahito
moves to the countryside with his father
who decides to marry the pregnant sister
of his late wife this understandably
upsets mahito who Retreats into a
fantasy world after a talking Heron
convinces him that his mother is still
alive in addition to being Loosely based
on the novel how do you live the boy and
the Heron may have also been inspired by
hay miyazaki's childhood G kids has
described it as a semi-autobiographical
fantasy and many reviewers have made
connection between the director's life
and the film story like mahito
miyazaki's father is known to have been
involved in the production of fighter
planes similarly miyazaki's family also
sought Refuge from the Tokyo bombings by
relocating to the Japanese Countryside
others have noted that the film's
opening scene of a hospital fire is seen
as a reflection of the loss of
miyazaki's mother with whom he shared a
strong bond and who was an influence on
many of his female characters critics
have also picked up on miyazaki's
signature motifs and recurring themes
within the film the boy and the Heron
was produced by Studio jibli co-founder
toshio Suzuki whose relationship with
Miyazaki stretches back before the
formation of the studio they first work
together on 1984's NASA of the Valley of
the wind the success of that film LED to
Miyazaki and Suzuki creating a new
studio along with ISO takaha and yasu
Yoshi tokuma while NASA is often
considered to be the unofficial first
Studio jibli Movie the first film to
actually be released under the banner
was 1986's Castle in the Sky Suzuki and
Miyazaki have gone on to work together
again on many occasions including
Spirited Away Princess Mononoke Howl's
Moving Castle and The Wind Rises outside
of Studio ji Suzuki's producing work
includes the cyberpunk classic Ghost in
the Shell 2
innocence the animation director for the
boy and the Heron is teshi Honda who
previously worked with Miyazaki on such
movies as Pono and The Wind Rises Honda
is also known for his contributions to
the anime franchises Evan gelian and the
film's Tokyo Godfathers and Millennium
actress 26 key animators worked on the
boy and the Heron most of whom have
previously worked with Miyazaki at some
point in his previous projects Miyazaki
was known for his Hands-On approach as
he oversaw every cut there is no
compromise not even the smallest most
insignificant line but in the case of
the boy and the Heron Miyazaki has
reportedly backed off a bit rather than
micromanaging the animation he's chosen
to instead Focus his time and energy on
Crafting the storyboards while
entrusting Honda to supervise the
animation process until the July 2023
Japanese release of the boy and the
Heron the only promotional material and
press permitted about the film was a
single poster drawn by hayo Miyazaki
himself according to the Mastermind
behind this marketing strategy toshio
Suzuki he was tired of over publicized
releases that gave away too much about a
movie he wanted to create an experience
wherein a viewer could go in blind with
as little information as possible it
appears that Suzuki has achieved his
goal as numerous movie goers attributed
their extraordinary experiences to this
unconventional marketing approach
however a new marketing strategy was
implemented when Studio jibli granted
promotional control to American
distributor G kids which planned to
orchestrate the biggest release the
company had ever seen keeping the film
shrouded in secrecy became challenging
as it's already been screened at
International venues and film festivals
still as G kids president Dave jet
explained to indiewire we're going to
continue to find ways to both make sure
that the film can reach its widest
possible audience while staying true to
a lot of the marketing and the Integrity
that Studio jibli has the boy and the
Heron is one of the longest films that
studio jibli has ever released clocking
in at 124 minutes it's just about the
same length as the Oscar winning
Spirited Away there are a few jibli
movies that are even longer though The
Wind Rises and Castle in the Sky both
clock in at 126 minutes while Princess
Mononoke is the second longest jly film
at 133 minutes but the title of longest
jibli feature goes to 2013's the tale of
the princess kaguya which runs 137 7
minutes that's more than an hour longer
than the Studio's shortest flick 2002's
the cat returns as for the rating the
boy and the Heron has been given a PG-13
for its depictions of violent content
bloody images and smoking miyazaki's
films have a reputation for appealing to
a broad audience and are typically
considered familyfriendly but this isn't
the first of his movies to be rated
PG-13 as the boy and the Heron will be
following in the footsteps of Princess
monoke and The Wind Rises ultimately the
rating isn't too surprising considering
that the boy and the Heron will deal
heavily with the themes of death
mortality and grief this world is filled
with the dead longtime Miyazaki
collaborator Joe HEI composed the
musical score for the boy and the Heron
the soundtrack consists of 37 original
compositions including the theme song
spinning globe from simple piano ballads
to captivating melodic strings the score
effectively sets the mood for the film
in an interview with Crunchyroll HEI
revealed I want my music to capture the
emotion and imagery as you watch the
film heii has worked on all all of
miyazaki's films except for his first
feature 1979's the castle of calostro
he's worked on more than 100 film scores
and solo albums throughout his career
and has won several Japanese Academy
Awards for Best Music the main theme for
the boy and the Heron is performed by
Japanese musician kenhi yzu though it
remains to be seen whether this song
will be included in the international
version where it will be titled spinning
globe yzu has previously recorded theme
songs for anime series like chainsaw man
my hero Academia and March comes in like
a lion to name a few Yu's career began
back in 2009 when he was just 18 he
started posting music on the Japanese
video sharing website nikiko Doga and
quickly gained a following as he
explained during a 2017 interview with
Yahoo Japan the core thing I pay most
heed to is looking for the common points
between myself and the other party those
who have already been lucky enough to
see the boy and the Heron have been
generally enthusiastic about it if early
reactions are anything to go by it
sounds like it's not miyazaki's best
film but still a worthy entry the BBC
for one compared it to past mizaki
Classics like Kiki's Delivery Service
and Spirited Away and Anime News Network
declared the film for all its
Fantastical trappings is the story of
mahito coming to accept what he still
has and fighting to make sure nothing
more is taken away from him it's a
thematically powerful narrative and one
that uses visual storytelling far more
than dialogue to get its message across
even critics who didn't connect with the
story have admitted that it is
technically brilliant as the website
full frontal put it I do not think that
it will work for everyone I'm not even
sure it worked for me but this
difficulty and ambiguity might be its
best quality miyazaki's ultimate
Showcase of talent nuance and
Imagination there's more work to be done
despite the lack of trailers the boy and
the Heron opened two record-breaking
figures in Japan thus proving The Genius
of toshio Suzuki's radical marketing
plan to get specific the movie posted
the best opening in the history of
Studio jibli as it made 1.83 billion yen
over its first weekend for context
Howell's moving Council made 1.48
billion yen over the same period back in
2004 the boy and the Heron also set a
new IMAX record in Japan making $1.7
million from Friday to Sunday that might
not sound like a huge figure but
Japanese movie goinging habits are very
different compared to the United States
with films typically earning money at a
slower pace and staying longer in
theaters as Word of Mouth spreads by the
end of the first week of October 2023
the boy and the Heron had grossed over
8.4 billion yen in Japan and the first
signs of what is expected to be a strong
overseas performance were showing it
also dominated the South Korean box
office in its opening weekend and also
broke opening day records when it hit
cineplexes in France time will tell very
soon if it can pull off the same feat in
[Music]
America